what's up y'all it's your boy doobie you
can catch me on the bootleg cab podcast
bootleg cat podcast special guest we're
in Arizona for the Super Bowl
and I found some I found some guy
outside
he was uh he was trying to hitchhike his
way back to Columbus
somehow you got lost in Arizona his name
is duby
what's up man
still trying to figure out how I got
here
me too
I know you and I'm like how do you get
this far without getting canceled or
[Music]
I I might have I might still be canceled
and just not know about it you might not
know it doobie what's up man you know
what's going on with you
new music been dropping a couple new
singles are out yeah new label situation
all that good jazz a lot going on
how you feeling
[Music]
same [__] different toilet
nice
it really is like just getting back to
it you know cover that everybody like on
this
Hiatus did you uh did you catch covered
um
you know it's crazy I think I did
but I it was never like I had to be on
bed rest or anything like that I just
lost did you ever get taste and smell oh
yeah then you got it it's like yeah
definitely
you definitely are how's the sober train
going you still on it
um well I don't do hard drugs I mean
that was my gist of I'm specifically
meaning are you still off the yayo yeah
for sure good job good job buddy almost
three years three it'll be three that's
[__] big man
that's a big deal brother which is also
my son's birthday so
a good reason to your son will be two or
three three
how's the father life going
it's gnarly
would you say two or three is the worst
year because sometimes they say they're
terrible too but I actually think three
is the really treacherous year as a
father those three is when they're
really [__] yeah it used to be
it used to be like this real a lot of
real cuteness yeah it's a little
terrorist living you're a little devil
aren't you oh yeah
I still love you a lot but damn you know
you're a little devil definitely
potty training
it's cool I'm just gonna say that have
you have you had your son pee or [__] on
you on accident yet yeah yeah me too
yeah and I'm not your son my son did
that to me when he was little man the
the [__] and why you why are you
trying to bathe him is the the craziest
[__] at least but at least that's like
that's kind of like nice
these are already in bathing position
you're already in bathing position
yeah it's a little you know [__]
floating uh how was the tour 54 dates
yes felt like you guys were on tour from
like was it like July to October or some
[__]
was that exactly right look at me
knowing a lot about y'all
[Laughter]
yeah it was uh it was actually
lit as [__] it looked like it man it was
it was super lit every night like ended
up being the most random places we'd be
like what the hell it's a line down it
would just be crazy I feel like last
year you kind of got like right like
kind of back to where you were in terms
of dropping and shooting videos doing
your thing was it nice to kind of get
that reaffirmation from the fans on the
road yeah because like during covert and
during the like that that time period
where I was first starting to get off
hard drugs and stuff
I really wasn't making no music and like
there was no inspiration there you know
I'd be at home changing diapers with my
son you failed me you couldn't go
anywhere so it was like the the spark of
creativity just wasn't there and I was
just working on myself so you feel me
from to go from that time period and
then to be able to you know put music
out that I've been waiting to put out
you know and see what the reaction would
be that was a that was like
awesome like like okay we still got it
we back in it you know what I'm saying
we just had to take some time off and
that's okay you know what I'm saying
what's it like being a white artist on
black noise
[Laughter]
I don't know how to answer that
I'm sure there's there's a couple other
white artists on black noise I'm just
curious
so
shout out to stretch shout out to the
guys over there Charlie and those guys
I'm just curious when they announced the
label name like a few years ago I was
like I wonder if you're gonna sign a
white guy and they they signed the white
guy the white guy the dude of dudes
yes I don't know it's great how's the
new I mean you work you're working a lot
I know you're trying to get this album
together
you got some songs you're very excited
about the people have not heard yet yes
sir
uh how's the new album coming along
well new album's been done for
I've been working on this new album so
so the crazy thing is I dropped two
albums last year which
we're pretty much done as well and then
I saved these records for this one for
this one for about so it's like two
years I've been working on this album
and I've pretty much have finished it up
[__] months ago we just been recording
new records now we're like hey Deluxe
maybe I don't know you know what I'm
saying but it's been done forever
when's it coming out
um I don't know yet
hmm
very soon next few months
what about the song that you're very
excited about the Celebrate song
what about it is it coming up it's it's
coming out and then and you know when it
does you're gonna be like
I hate that song I don't like it but I
get it
I understand I understand why everyone
else likes it he just he just don't want
to celebrate uh that's the thing he just
wants to go to sleep when we walked in
here he was asleep he was like I was I
was on the couch [__] death I hate
this what's up guys hey shout out to our
family at uh Bluetooth man listen I know
we always are getting feedback about our
Bluetooth interviews
they're not interviews yeah they're
commercials and we're always getting
feedback about them usually it's their
[__] hilarious man
you know people love it when we talk
about Bluetooth but let me say this [__]
works a lot of people are like look man
I see you talking about Bluetooth but
does it work yes it works if y'all don't
know Bluetooth it's got the same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis but in a
chewable form it's delivered to your
door
in a discrete package and you don't have
to go inside of a doctor's office to get
it no awkward doctor visits involved
everything is online that's right you go
to bluetooth.com use the promo code
bootleg they will send you a month for
free a month supply of Bluetooth for
free five dollars shipping that's it and
they'll be like damn Kev
you were right bro my erections are lit
as they should be every
erection should be
as erect as possible you know you don't
want to be flaccid you don't want to be
one of those 70 30 guys you know that
means that 30 of your dicks potentially
hardness is being uh
underutilized
could you use an extra 30 hard maybe 50
hard I don't know it depends on what
you're dealing with they're dealing with
stress in your life
are you tired of having sex with your
girlfriend
hard to get it up well go to
bluetooth.com right now use the promo
code bootleg they're going to send you a
month for free they also just drop the
mint chewable same active ingredient as
Levitra that's right so what you need to
do I mean you don't need to do anything
if you want to you know not be as hard
as you can be that's on you bud
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
and try it for free a month supply free
delivered to your door no awkward doctor
appointment needed it's all online all
right bluetooth.com
also want to shout out to our family
over at Odd Socks that's right as
someone who wears Odd Socks every day
I'll prove it to you I'm in Arizona
right now this is just random
we got The Odd Socks underwear right
there I mean that's Odd Socks and we got
the hot sauce Basics baby yeah so look
so this was stuff about Odd Socks man
um not only do they got the most
comfortable socks in the world because
they do I'm not just saying that because
they sponsor our show it's true uh they
also got some of the crazy licenses they
just got Coca-Cola uh they got Doritos
they got [__] everything they got
Scarface Godfather
uh Breaking Bad WWE we can go on and on
and on underwear socks slippers hats all
kinds of cool stuff
oddsoxofficial.com right now use the
promo code bootleg and you will save 20
off at checkout try the odd Sox Basics
if you're one of those guys who wears
other plain white branded socks plain
black socks I promise you go with the
odd Sox basics
and you will believe me but just you
will convert over they're way more
comfortable
they're way more durable
and they just they're Odd Socks why
would you wear those other socks we
could wear on socks bro stand out and be
odd go to oddsocksofficial.com use the
promo code bootleg
let's get back to the interview
um any well first of all how's everybody
on the label doing your label
what do you mean I mean you're crew the
crew Oh I thought you was talking I
don't know what you know that's scfg fmg
[__] everybody's killing it I mean
um crash has been dropping like crazy
right now he's he's working on movies
writing a movie and shooting a movie
he's killing [__] count is always
putting out Dope music man I'm pretty
sure you know he just dropped a album
not too long ago we got a song on there
called glass house I think the album's
called glass house too and then um shout
out to fat foolio
free fat fully awesome that's a great
name
he's he's killing [__] man and Swan's
about to drop some crazy [__] so
everybody's killing [__] you know and
light and John Bonner are killing it on
the on the on the on the flip side on
the other side on the business tip so
for you like uh
you've had a pretty crazy journey
through music in terms of just like
you're a new artist but you're not a new
artist you've been grinding at this [__]
forever yeah to kind of like finally get
some recognition
in terms of like because you know I feel
like me and you would talk a few years
ago and I feel like you kind of had a
chip on your shoulder because
you met you wouldn't get the the
academics as of the world are there no
jumpers of the world and I used to tell
you like bro who gives a [__] like don't
worry about that [__] that [__] don't
mean nothing like it'll come to you and
I do I felt like recently I saw
when your deal got announced or I just
saw you on one of those blogs that we
used to talk about and so like for you
do you feel like
uh you know obviously the hard work's
been paying off you're financially
stable you get to tour the country and
meet your fans and do you feel like
within the industry you're finally kind
of starting to get into that door where
you know
you're being a little bit more accepted
and acknowledged for the movement you
guys even highlight I've been building
all these years
um it's kind of like a yay and a type of
thing right I feel like there's still so
much that is to be told you know and
known about so but
um at the same time we've been getting a
lot of love you know so it's never about
just the the negative part of things too
so we appreciate everything
but I do feel like
it's it's still a lot of [__]
who need to know who I am of course you
know what I'm saying
but yeah any any features on the uh on
the uh the new album
that's been done for two years
honestly there's only one feature on the
whole album
and she's an amazing writer artist her
name is Kennedy
Kennedy with a with an i at the end
check her out she's fired
um also co-writer on the song we
celebrate too okay so
with uh
fresh as well shout out to Fresh
are you
for you like one thing that I loved what
y'all were doing was like it felt like
all your guys's artwork was kind of like
uniform for a while
you had the guy doing the illustrations
and [__] we lost him
we don't know where he's at yeah what
happened to that guy yeah where are you
at dude like we miss you I was gonna say
like in terms of just like the imagery
the music video I feel like you guys
have always had like a very like well
thought out
you like purposeful way you Market your
[__]
um what is that thought process when
you're going to thinking about like I
mean how this album's gonna look how
this artwork's gonna feel like you know
what I mean I mean I just basically like
a lot of that is like on the creative
side of like how to Market it really be
like highlight
take it because he knows the things that
I like you feel me so I just like I like
this this and he takes it and creates
the plan you know behind it and it's
usually 10 out of 10 we're squared away
you know it's a mixture of all that and
then
anything that we need done to to make it
to execute it you know Joe's right there
to make sure it happens so you feel me
it's just like it's Collective
you uh I don't know if I I talked to you
about this last time I saw you but you
obviously you had a big loss in your
life the homie Big Mike yeah passed away
during the during the pandemic uh yeah
yeah uh and he was very important to you
uh
and you know you're always doing it for
Big Mike you know keeping his memory
alive but like how was losing somebody
like him
while also becoming a father
how how is that kind of like shaped you
man because you know losing somebody
that's that close to you you know it
could motivate you it could make you
sad depressed it could do a lot like you
know it definitely uh
it's like a Bittersweet moment right
because Big Mike was usually the one
like if we were all in the studio
together and stuff
he'll be the one like bobbing his head
right I'm like yeah that's it he was
like that's it right you feel me so
just remembering the moments and then
the most the worst part about it I think
um
was that he didn't get to meet my son
before he passed and he was just like so
excited for me to be a father because he
was an amazing father you feel I mean
that was something that I admired about
him right you know what I'm saying and
so I couldn't wait for my son to be born
so that he could meet him and you know
it didn't get to happen but um
the crazy thing is though after that
happened I was that was my I'm trying to
get sober of hard drugs phase and all
this [__] so I'm like
I was honestly very depressed for a
couple years you know what I'm saying I
feel like now I'm finally getting out of
that and and we back in the groove going
hard you know what I'm saying going out
you know meeting people shaking hands
getting in these these parties with the
places we need to get you know to get
this music out there just back on that
old grind you feel me I feel like we're
we're back at a good place we took our
time off to grieve and and I know that
he would want us to go crazy so we gotta
do it big for him too what's up y'all
bootleg Kev here hey look my boogie man
it's a big weekend in sports the big
game is Sunday Chiefs versus Eagles I'm
all in on the Eagles
I like Jalen hurts over on the passing
yards over on the rushing yards anytime
touchdown score give me Dallas got her
anytime touchdown score give me the over
and if anyone on the Chiefs is going to
score I like that Pacheco kid I like the
little running back guy and of course
you gotta Hammer Travis Kelsey anytime
touchdown score you could do all that at
my bookie right now all right so many
props to bet on at my bookie this
weekend you can bet on the Gatorade
color that gets poured out you could bet
on the on the flip the the coin flip at
the beginning of the game all that right
now at my bookie sign up with the promo
code bootleg when you sign up they will
match your very first deposit up to one
thousand dollars with that promo code
bootleg so go to mybookie.ag sign up for
an account
promo code bootleg whatever you put in
they're gonna double it
as long as it's not more than a thousand
you put 999 dollars in they're gonna
give you another 9.99
you put a thousand in they gave you
another thousand by the way if you do
the 9.99 why not just do the full
thousand you cheap bastard anyway my
bookie right now man it's a big weekend
also I just would like to point out
everyone should be putting some of that
money sprinkling a little bit of that
action on the Phoenix Suns win the
championship this year because we have
Kevin Durant oh yeah oh yeah my bookie
sign up with that promo code bootleg
also shout out to our family at hardean
Jardine Las Vegas Yes you see him
I was just there in Vegas yesterday this
is the best place I've ever been to in
terms of dispensaries I've been to
probably hundreds of these things and
the experience at hardean is like
nowhere else
the customer service the selection of
Premium cannabis the experience as a
customer that you get when you walk into
the building in Las Vegas is a bar none
the best it's just the best man they are
the best we got so much going on this
weekend they're sponsoring the Rolling
Stone party on Friday Super Bowl weekend
fabulous Thursday offset Friday Meek
Saturday it's a lot going on with hard
Dean you got to follow him at hardean
underscore Las Vegas right now shoot
them a follow on Instagram while you're
at it go to their website
hardinglasvegas.com so much fly gear so
much fly weed what are we talking about
baby shout out to hardine man that's the
family man go if you're in Vegas pull up
on them man Jardine Las Vegas yo
have you and uh I feel like um
it's it's crazy to me that you and
Cassie haven't done like a little like
joint EP or something at this point with
all the goddamn music and touring y'all
have done together have you guys ever
talked about that the crazy thing is on
tour
uh shout out to casket because he was on
tour how many records did we do in like
three days
it's like
for a mixtape but then it was like 13
all together
so we we have the music right
doesn't matter it's a matter of when is
it ever going to come out
it I mean it should in the future for
sure it's like touring sober and he's
like you know wakes up does burpees and
drinks coffee and doesn't do it like
totally different vibe on this tour than
like previous tours in terms of
debauchery and just like
definitely like
bro it's definitely like just like how
you said like he gets up and he'll just
like you'll have a con while you're
having a conversation with him he's just
doing burpees out of nowhere right and
then me I'm like dude uh do we get
Miller lights yet
so you know but it evens out like right
guys can get along perfectly well you
know what I'm saying like it's it's
funny as hell though because we're polar
oppositions yeah I'm dying passing me to
brew I'm chilling you go ahead and do
the burpees I'm gonna do kush-ups and
wear straight push-ups and burpees
that's the name of the [__] collab EP
there it is
Kush up some burpees I'm not mad at that
uh well look hopefully we get this new
album soon man sooner than later no
it'll be out real soon much sooner than
anything do you have a name
the thing is you know the name but I'm
not going to tell you the name
doing everything
you know the name
I don't know her name you you really do
that's the crazy thing
oh holy Center nah what's
we'll talk about it
was the goth Surfer nah
I'm looking at the object
which is called doobie self-titled
self-titled would you look at that would
you look at that I told you we got it
the self-titled album finally coming
soon
by the way
what was the [__] song The interlude
on the [__] album from like 2018 or
19 it's like my sh Fe you're so
different I still listen to my [__] all
the time
that beat breakdown in that [__]
that [__]
bro I just I'm like back and forth
between that and the club
great clever song
is so good I love that word cops are
clever what happened to clever man we
gotta he's such a great voice he just
dropped another record as far as caught
a red on the carpet super talented kid
man
grown man anyway DJ highlights gonna go
put a sweater on he's cold I'm [__]
freezing inside I'm shivering I don't
know if y'all can see me I'm cold it is
freezing in here
um look new album self-titled coming up
before summer
before summer yeah yeah okay
who you got in the Super Bowl
I don't want to talk about this [__]
well who's you who's your teammate the
real team the Bengals team never
America's team oh you're a Cowboys fan
the real Dallas Cowboys oh
the only team
well that sucks this is crazy why your
dad yeah your dad was a fan yeah shout
out to him pretty much well
and then so I grew up so just like this
Ohio State Buckeyes and the Cowboys
pretty much wow I also like well yeah
I'm Ohio State Buckeye throwing through
right like Notre Dame too in college
that's interesting yeah but if it's it's
Ohio State against the world
I like that
[__] the Cowboys that's crazy well hey
why aren't you going for Joey B bruh in
your state go for Joey burrow bruh I see
this [__] guy this [__] fake ass
49ers
and then he takes the [__] Jersey off
and he's got the Joey B underneath of it
if everything hey at least you got an
AFC and NFC
I respect it
I [__] with your world
I wish he would play for my team
isn't there a hockey team in Columbus
Blue Jackets nice Columbus Blue Jackets
all right man well look appreciate y'all
coming through doobie the new album soon
new single soon
you got a couple of songs out currently
there's a meditation and all him out on
all platforms whether YouTube
yes what are you trying to say highlight
this will probably drop like Monday
this
so Friday a new song
if Love Don't Cost a Thing February 17th
is that a movie
song and video anything else Joe
anything else Joe
oh yeah we got a lot we got a lot to
celebrate this year so much so much
Joe's favorite song
let's go doobie he hates the song too
I don't hate the song I don't love it
though
no Joe's sucking that song If that song
had a dick Joby [__] Joby
anyway
all right all right guys we're gonna end
we're gonna end the interview
doobie
peace